est ce que vous avez envie de partir
vous envoler avec moi ou avec nous ce
soir je suis comme nous a dit notre
collègue une cela chesea une jeune
chercheuse jobs sérieuse depuis presque
13 ans et puis la chose depuis presque
six ans vous allez découvrir dans ce vin
qu'on va faire ensemble ce que c'est une
job fair use est ce que c'est une
slameuse vous découvrir un petit peu ce
monde atypique qu'on connaît qu'on voit
aujourd'hui et qui nous permet à tout
petit peu de découvrir l'anticonformisme
qui est le thème aussi la conférence
aujourd'hui on va changer un tout petit
peu d'altitude ou plutôt d'attitude sur
le marché de l'emploi d'attitude parce
que on en amont d'un petit peu
particulier qui nous touche tous où tout
change la vie les relations de travail
on est dans un monde un petit peu
incertain on a besoin surtout de se
réinventer
on va par courrier un petit envol
ensemble si vous êtes prêts à décoller a
démarré avec moi un vol à plus de 10
mille mètres d'altitude
on va commencer à bord à découvrir nos
co pilote qui sont là des copilotes qui
sont super actif qui vont démarrer
décoller dans quelques instants avec
nous la femme qu'on voit à droite qui
est beaucoup plus expérimenté pilote de
ligne
hélas ma gauche qui a 10 ans 2 mois ce
qu'on appelle un job sharing inter
générationnelle ils sont là les deux
pilotes aujourd'hui 221 passagers à bord
on est encore dans une situation de
posco vide où les vols vont reprendre
mais où le monde sera certainement un
tout petit peu différent plus comme
avant on l'espère avec éventuellement
aussi une amélioration de certaines
normes de travail et autres qu'est ce
que c'est le job sharing
voyez le moc éco-responsabilité deux
copilotes font quoi il pilote à deux un
avion ils vont nous amener on va vous
amener maintenant depuis l'europe outre
atlantique de plus en plus vers l'ouest
ils sont des copilotes des
co-responsables et il vous explique tout
de suite que c'est le job et le top
schering quèsaco qu'est ce que c'est ce
concept cet anglicisme un job sharing
c'est tout simple c'est un poste à 100%
qu'on partage
à deux trois personnes avec une
coresponsabilité avec surtout des
valeurs des visions communes comme une
sorte de directives ou vous prenez
l'avion vous partez ensemble vous allez
vous envolez vous allez découvrir autre
chose autre horizon partir mais ensemble
un côté collaboratif participatif où on
espère aussi prendre intégré plusieurs
éléments le thatchérisme
le mot l'indiqué du top ce sont des jobs
scherrer qui vont diriger qui vont
conduire quand vous faites par exemple
une conduite de 20 à 30 personnes
toujours dans cette conception encore
hiérarchique qui existe parmi nous
d'autres concepts se mettre sur pied
aussi comme vous le savez la lacra si
les méthodes horizontal où on peut
carrément faire un autre monde du
travail
le job l'étape cyril sont pas des
concepts nouveaux
depuis 45 ans ça existe créé aux états
unis en 1976 par une économie américaine
qui voulait aussi à l'époque déjà à
changer la donne
aujourd'hui vous allez le voir le djia
fier il permet surtout d'arriver plus
vite à communiquer grâce à la
numérisation un check-in on est à bord
on prend l'avion on est en plein
check-in qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'on
fasse maintenant on peut pas monter à
bord d'un avion comme ça on est obligées
à un tout petit peu de se retrouver pour
qui et c'est le job sharing le job et le
top schering touche toutes les
générations
les gens plus jeunes qui sont en train
d'intégrer son marché de l'emploi qui
sont souvent un job qui sont étudiants
qui veut faire un post avoir un poste
intéressant et puis aussi pouvoir avoir
un peu de temps libre
un peu du free time qu'on appelle ça
comment est ce qu'on peut trouver aussi
d'autres générations les gens qui sont
un tout petit peu plus âgé les gens qui
sont avec des familles des enfants entre
25 ans et 45 ans qui ont eu envie de
aussi de concilier la vie
professionnelle et la vie familiale
et puis les gens qui ont 50 ans et plus
ce qu'on oublie parfois un tout petit
peut remarcher travail
ceci aussi s'y intéressent souvent ils
ont envie un tout petit peu de lâcher
prise et de devenir aussi des slashers
d'être encore un petit peu salariés et
en parallèle de pouvoir travailler comme
indépendants de créer veulent être aussi
un petit peu de rêve
ce qui les intéresse comment est ce
qu'on trouve un partenaire imaginer brit
air
j'ai un partenaire vous devez trouver
quelqu'un qui vous sied alors comme
partout dans ce monde tout est
virtualisé
il ya des plates formes de mise en
partenariat par algorithmes mais il ya
aussi des réseaux toussainte des
connaissances que vous avez pour trouver
le ou la partenaire et les conditions de
base est ce que vous vous vous vous
pouvez faire du job sharing
et bien non pas tout le monde peut le
faire il ya quelques conditions de base
la première c'est la souplesse d'être
hyper soupe ouvert d'esprit près la
critique toujours vous serez à 2 comme
les copilotes qu'on a à bord maintenant
toujours à dur d'une pensée qui sera
ensemble la confiance aussi est
phénoménale est impressionnante dans le
job sharing pour avancer ensemble
et puis aussi d'être capable de se
remettre en question d'arriver à un
moment donné de se dire on peut aussi
parfois changer de directives de voix
flexibilité souplesse et surtout cette
ouverture d'esprit on est un petit peu
en train de décoller maintenant on le
sent vous le reconnaissez sur l'image on
se trouve sur la montagne des anges et
mühleberg en suisse orientale
on est maintenant à 5000 mètres
d'altitude vous le sentez ça commence à
devenir très sympathique
le soleil rentrer par les hublots on est
un peu apaisé on se met en route
on commence à sers du job sharing à le
sentir ce que c'est quand on travaille à
deux dans une vision commune
quand on est en train de partir ensemble
là je fais un petit clin d'oeil à ma
partenaire en job sharing je suis depuis
13 ans on partage emploi depuis trois
ans avec une collègue qui vient de cette
région et on découvre beaucoup de choses
avec les partenaires pas seulement le
travail mais toute une autre dimension
un petit clin d'oeil à ma collègue
jacques chirac était aussi ici en
virtuel qu'est ce que c'est la pensée du
job sharing ou va-t-en avec ça qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec ce style qu'elles sont
un petit peu l'impact pendant au niveau
du cerveau ce sont en fait deux cerveaux
complémentaires ou similaires si vous
postulez un jour en dia ping si vous
décidez un jour de le faire vous allez
simplement postuler avec quelqu'un qui
va soit donner autre chose que vous ou
bien alors quelqu'un qui est un peu
semblable pour travailler comme vous
tous se voit au niveau du job sharing
les cerveaux sent toujours relié à des
reconnecter une juxtaposition en fait
des esprits complémentaires ou
similaires rien n'est meilleur que
l'autre
tous se retrouvent des compétences qu'on
trouve nulle part ailleurs
si vous postulez pour un passe
aujourd'hui en job sharing vous allez
fournit aux recruteurs ceux qui ne
trouvent jamais la constellation de deux
cerveaux en a des compétences au niveau
linguistique des compétences au niveau
professionnel vous aurez toujours une
plus value sur la personne qui va
postuler sun le duo en job sharing c'est
aussi une pensée différente
c'est aussi d'apprendre par l'autre je
fais depuis 13 ans du job sharing ma
collègue au départ avec qui il
travaillait 9 ans je ne la connaissais
pas du tout on a appris à se connaître
en étant dans un job sharing
on apprend parfois même plus de la
personne dans un job cher que de
l'entourage
on est toujours dans une sorte de
symbiose au niveau intellectuel et au
niveau du travail on arrive à un tout
petit peu maintenant à 10000 mètres
d'altitude
on a reçu un peu un lunch on est un peu
plus apaisé on peut un peu se reposer
décollage a réussi nos deux copilotes
sont le cockpit
il vous emporte vous vous sentez assez
bien là je vois dans vos visages là en
virtuel sur tout mais assez relax renac
certains s'endorment un petit peu
d'autre part l'autre sont réveillés dans
un moment qui est vraiment pas si mal
pour pouvoir réfléchir plus loin
quels sont les avantages du partage
d'emplois qu'est ce qui amène mieux au
plus loin un employé vous vous vous
qu'est-ce qui vous donnerait une plus
value de postuler en job sharing d'abord
vous allez toucher ce conte où jamais
les postes les plus intéressants en
suisse on fait partie du pays qui avant
un tiers de travailleurs à temps partiel
on est le paradis du temps partiel le
temps partiel c'est aussi un piège
ça permet de concilier vie familiale et
vie professionnelle
mais ça permet aussi de rester confinés
dans des postes souvent pas intéressant
en postulant à deux avec un ou une
partenaire
vous allez réussir simplement à trouver
des postes beaucoup plus intéressant
pour les employés ya aussi une plus
value ne pas être seule image et tous
ces chefs qui postulent qui sont
endeuillées
archi très grande qui dirige 50 cents
personnes et qui souvent sont remués
d'un poste à l'autre qui font ce petit
climbing cette remontée par rapport à la
hiérarchie
si jean mas souffre se sont souvent très
seul le job sharing permet aussi d'être
ensemble dans des prises de décisions
qui sont beaucoup plus complexes pour
l'employeur la situation était un petit
peu différente
on va vous vendre tout de suite c'est
trop cher c'est trop compliqué le job
sharing le top sharing je connais pas ça
m'intéresse pas c'est un peu compliqué
eh bien non la productivité pour un
employeur être est ce que cumuler à 70 %
de votre activité professionnelle donc
le jeudi à midi votre rendement
productif diminue si vous avez une
juxtaposition de deux personnes à ce
moment là vous atteignez une beaucoup
plus grande plus-value au niveau de
votre productivité pour un employeur
c'est autre chose d'avoir deux têtes
pensantes des décisions aussi beaucoup
plus aboutie et surtout un point
fondamental la rétention de talent
qu'est ce que ça veut dire vrai le
talent de pouvoir retenir surtout ces
femmes qui à 30 ans en leur premier
enfant sont là dans un milieu
professionnel hautement performante et
auquel on dit tout d'un coup tu à temps
partiel
on peut plus de proposer ce poste on
peut par des modèles de travail qui sont
novateurs on peut révolutionner faire
avancer et surtout retenir le capital
humain
un exemple super intéressant la médecine
ou le droit où on trouve aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus de femmes qui sont formés
au niveau de la médecine que dame ou des
personnes qui arrivent à un moment de
leur vie où elles ont beaucoup moins de
possibilités de faire carrière important
c'est qu'on sait que la de les retenir
de pouvoir leur fournir d'autres modèles
de travail et le branding la publicité
pour les firmes de plus en plus de
firmes cherche à avoir des modèles pour
attirer des jeunes surtout la génération
y ou z cette génération qui cherche
beaucoup plus à concilier le temps
partiel et avec une vie privée et une
vie professionnelle qui soit harmonieuse
pour la société aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que ça peut signifier imaginé ce monde
posco vide quelques instants qu'est ce
que ça peut signifier
et si vous êtes dans une situation où de
plus en plus de gens seront licenciés là
aussi le partage en place et une
redéfinition des équivalents plein temps
des différents pourcentages de travail
et aussi plus d'équité
vous arrivez par là un processus de
socialisation et s'auto au niveau de
l'équité sociale qui est plus grande
et puis enfin le job sharing atom vous
vous est-ce que vous travaillez de
manière équitable avec votre partenaire
vous partager les tâches domestiques
est ce que vous avancez ensemble dans ce
domaine là on vous partageant les choses
le job sharing trop mais c'est l'autre
côté de côté vous pouvez partager vous
avez différemment votre temps alloué
avec votre partenaire
j'ai trois enfants moi même j'ai
commencé le job sharing ya 13 ans quand
ma plus jeune avait deux ans c'est ce
qui m'a permis aussi avec mon partenaire
de pouvoir rééquilibrer de travail un
plus un font trois le djia c'est
peut-être ça le message de plus
important c'est une productivité et
c'est aussi une manière de pouvoir
avancer
une manière de pouvoir aussi se sentir
peut-être dans un team plus fort et ça
permet s'auto autre chose aussi d'ouvrir
la porte à d'autres horizons
le slash de slash cabriès c'est de
pouvoir aussi créer à côté de votre
travail
autre chose une entreprise une start up
ou même vos hobbies peut être carrément
livre dans autre chose d'un cumul que
vous avez ce que vous ressentez qui vous
amène plus loin un plus un font trois on
est en train de voler en quoi un tout
petit peu à 10000 mètres
on commence un petit peu à santé à
température qui changent vous le sentez
aussi on avait un petit peu de soleil
envoyait le soleil au dessus des nuages
maintenant commence un peu à réaliser
qui a des troubles
un peu de nuages qui viennent des défis
qu'est ce qui pose problème dans un job
chez qu'est ce qui peut être un problème
d'une part les échanges d'informations
on vous dira c'est trop compliqué et
bien non la numérisation
elle vous permet d'avancer d'avancé
relativement bien puisque tout est
interconnecté
quand j'ai travaillé dans un milieu
international on pourrait être n'importe
quel pays du monde et on pouvait
directement être en lien
intellectuellement avec le partenaire
les coûts additionnels
non ils sont très bas des coûts fixes
n'est pas trop élevé tous ces arguments
là se valent peuvent être après mire en
compensation avec une autre forme de
productivité c'est celle du travail
la numérisation a été pour nous
peut-être l'une des plus grandes
évolutions au niveau du jazz cher on est
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de gens qui
sont attirés par ce modèle c'est surtout
lié au fait que tout est numérique et
tout est rapide
on se partage des points des documents
il n'y a pratiquement plus besoin
d'avoir cet échange d'information comme
avant c'est ce qui permet aujourd'hui
dans un monde surtout en suisse ou le
temps partiel est tellement élevé où on
peut le faire de plus en plus
fréquemment
on est à paradis du temps partiel en
suisse avec aujourd'hui six femmes sur
dix qui travaillent à temps partiel et
deux hommes sur dix encore un
déséquilibre entre hommes et femmes mais
un très beau un très beau potentiel de
base pour le job chez eux on peut voir
ce modèle comme un modèle qui est avant
gardiste qui avancent parfois il ya
aussi des turbulences on arrive ici on
peut parfois avoir des moments dans
cette relation avec l'autre de
malentendus de prise de décision hâtive
de différent dans le sens de ciel change
on est toujours en vol on remarque c'est
un tout petit peu moins sûr on avance un
petit peu moins bien en ce moment
les copilotes sans situations un peu
plus difficile ils savent pas pourquoi
faire ils sont en train de délibérer de
voir s'ils peuvent atterrir s'ils
peuvent continuer tout devient plus
grave en ce moment la tension a pu forte
le différend n'est pas encore là mais le
malentendu de plus en plus fort
silence quelques instants réflexion les
copilotes sont en train de poser se
poser la question de leur route et ils
décident ils vont atterrir maintenant
dans quelques instants
le voyage est beaucoup plus loin on a
quitté l'europe on se positionne
ailleurs boeing one one tree hill wood
swan mairie
[Musique]
que new york austin jackson 5
ça c'est du sport comme ça dans le job
chez elle c'est toujours l'autre penser
qu'ils t'ont connexion c'est un des
robes qui est à austin texas y en a
beaucoup au niveau mondial jobs chaîne
est puissamment nationale c'est un
mouvement jackson c'est un développement
professionnel personnel vous l'avez
senti c'est surtout une route quand même
ensemble une route qu'on fait pour
découvrir un autre horizon c'est aussi
un vol qui surprend et qui permet
surtout d'avancé et c'est un vol qui n'a
aucune empreinte environnementale
l'empreinte carbone reste 0 j'espère que
vous allez repartir avec notre boeing
one one three want the swan mix-prix
thank you
[Applaudissements]